the bulb Snatchers are at work yeah we
need more light in here I'll replace
these dim bulbs with General Electric
chopped white for more than 125 years
General Electric has been selling its
light bulbs to the world this is the
soft pure light of the genii software
bulb but according to a report in The
Wall Street Journal
GE might be looking to shed its consumer
lighting unit ge was founded by Thomas
Edison in the 1890s as a means of
selling his most important invention the
light bulb with revenues powered by the
light bulb the company grew into one of
the biggest conglomerates in the world
over the next centuries we're in the
business of making products that make
your life a little easier
GE forged an identity by making a range
of familiar household appliances but as
times gone on the company's commercial
revenues have surged prompting GE to
sell off many of its consumer holdings
that includes last year's sale of its
appliance division to the Chinese firm
higher
now GE is transforming itself into a
digital company focusing on industrial
needs now the next phase is the investor
Internet it's going to be a multi
hundred billion dollar industry and
we're just in the very beginning phases
last year GES lighting business
accounted for less than 2% of the
company's revenue meaning the time may
be coming for General Electric to turn
out the lights on its bulb business you
know I will say George Westinghouse also
wanted a patent for the light we give
Thomas Alva Edison the credit in that
story but it was a war well Westinghouse
has also struggled to re-identify
identify itself we have to change that
old slogan that we bring in things to
light right we bring good things to the
industry